One of the most controversial topics in Korea...
... revolves around the teaching of English and foreign English teachers working here.
On one hand, there are some of the famous Korean professors of English education,...
...members of activist groups, media elites, and conservative traditionalists...
... who feel English is a toxic language...
...that kills the local language and culture everywhere it goes.
On the contrary, many people,...
...especially high level government and business professionals...
... that argue that without high skill in English as an international language,...
...Korea would not do as well as it has in the international economic and scientific arena.
Therefore Koreans must continue to improve in English...
...at all levels in all fields to strengthen national competitiveness.
Often how people react to English depends on their first experiences with it.
If their teachers liked English and infected students with their enthusiasm,...
...then frequently those students continue to excel in English throughout their whole life.
Korea has some truly excellent and well - qualified foreign and native - born instructors.
It also has some who are not excellent, but excrement.
The challenge is how to hire only the qualified and pay them appropriately.
Until a way to prevent the bad and unqualified ones from being employed...
...by disreputable institutes and illegal brokers is found,...
...it's "caveat emptor" for all students of English.